[Music]
and thinking way outside the box news
I'd like that to somebody by watching JK
during class nice good for you I'm
learning something in class more here
than whatever you're in a PhD student
that right there
a man collect a man Clark there's nail
clippings to create a unique engagement
ring diamond holy [ __ ] [ __ ] you like
the sentimental value type stuff what
sentimental value so do I haven't honed
that like having a piece of me on you
baby
oh [ __ ] do I want of you on meals
whenever I ever could you already would
want a piece of me when it's so
sentimental no what have I collected
that's all she'll give you a necklace
dip in his sweat or some [ __ ] instead of
like a tear jar it's a sweat jar yeah
you know girls tell you things and then
when you do it exactly what they say
you're wrong not all girls are the same
but if they share the same race there
let me have the same thoughts exactly so
anyway here we're talking about this
Japanese man of course are we surprised
Japanese definitely think outside the
box
yep like this [ __ ] over there
good job so this guy he has a YouTube
channel that is popular because he yeah
he's on YouTube so my brother just look
at me just look at Joe for a second with
stupid [ __ ] glasses on it makes me
laugh just see them sit there with his
glasses on with a straight face makes me
laugh straight face let's talk about my
ancestors come on yes he has he has
these these videos these how-to videos
for making super sharp knives out of
virtually anything he's even made a
sharp Knight a knife out of paper out of
tofu like out of everything but tofu
yeah
damn get those world's most softest food
and [ __ ] make a knife out of it yeah
you know what he was too crazy lengths
to do this so it likes university yeah
crazy like also known as Folsom alright
so I'm going to show you guys a video
clip of how he created this is his name
Takashi no it's cool it doesn't look
like nails
q ami yeah so this is what the ring
looks like ok he actually created the
ring part as well the diet the diamond
part he did it but now she has a part of
him it's fingernails on we're gonna need
your waste products that a metal [ __ ]
okay this Japanese man is so like I use
a fingernail and intended to put it in
oh my god that's the dedication I like
cuz he blends even just like the I hope
he doesn't juice with that blender oh my
dear Lord she washes it with all that
toe jam oh my god it's like sand that is
beautiful mix it with water hope he
doesn't eat with that pan piece that's I
think impressive no no I can't wait any
more
how thoughtful whoa toe juice right
there
well it's from is like fingernail they
put it in an oven for 90 minutes I'd
rather watch the bone or [ __ ] getting
cut in half again what look at trade
black yeah what is that
toenail oh my god what did he put on it
to make it black I miss it cuz I was gay
oh he was he baked it for nine hours all
it took was water is not like and
complain water compressed it in like
into a mold to make it look like a
diamond I'm surprised that it held and
it holds together with just water water
and baking
well he made a silver ring it's so
romantic but look um this is his
girlfriend that he puts it on yeah here
we go
actually I don't know
in this video fiancée oh it's not in the
video it just being like a mannequin oh
okay so he doesn't have a girlfriend
that was a joke I'm surprised his videos
because I saw some of his videos and
they always seem to be like I killed you
if you only see his hands like creating
these things but like sometimes he'll do
something like funny where it like
there's a bag of chips and he brings out
like a cucumber like it's like funny
with his hand shaking when he was about
to touch the Medicaid and in like yeah
like it's like something like like he's
like making fun of it it's a great
subtly making fun of it let's hope so
hey I hope so yeah but there's some
things around like okay this is clearly
he's joking they usually are like when
they marry robots and [ __ ] like that
like third they're in it but they're
joking like there would mean they're
eating good like it's like um so like
that whole I think it's catching on to
the states now with the whole cosplay
and the roleplay thingy but over there
like some people they role played so
much to the point where like that's 70%
their lives but they know that it's a
meme though they know that they're
playing it's just that we take it
seriously
at what cost sir at the cost of their
sexuality to all women forever at the
cost of their they're bored and they
want to be funny so this video it was
posted back in July and it has 5.6
million views it's like the prestige you
know the show must go on
like they go in to to be the to be the
troll but by that by that time are you
now actually just that no longer the
troll at him that's the fear if they
come this new being you start to
actually do this stuff and you becoming
yeah yeah how did that guy idea even
come up he's just clipping his nails
what have I made a ring out of this like
how does that you have to be in some
other level [ __ ] to kind of think of
that so usually bored
cuz if you actually see like I saw the
one where he made a knife out of paper
and it was it's a cute tiny little knife
to but like he went to some creepy
actually
went to a river like he created this
contraption out of a plastic bottle to
put the pace that he created with the
water water and paper and [ __ ] and then
she put it in this thing and then he put
like this wire around it so then he went
to a river a local extreme and as the
stream was going like it's it's pretty
much like a natural sir computer
centrifuge thank you centrifuge so it's
like spinning and spinning and it
creates like this crazy little paste but
I'm like how do you even think of it
[ __ ] that's so and then that was like
days of leading or like Oh weeks like a
whole week oh so you're telling me if I
didn't jack off all day I can actually
be related and skilled and that refused
to be done - there's jizz on that
mannequin true I don't think he doesn't
do jack off all day yeah I think I think
this is his jag off well he'd this hat I
didn't know this is a whole youtube
channel so this obviously he does this
as an angle right sharpest shark teeth
kitchen knife in the world yes oh he's
just made from hair this is what he does
he makes weird [ __ ] to get views the
mixer sharpest jello kitchen knife what
did the views like sixteen million
pretty good really good twenty million
we don't have a 16 million no he's
ballin today he probably has [ __ ] and
hookers all over the place oh hi Joe
happened to your ancestors we need
[ __ ] and huggers you can afford both
that [ __ ] always blows my mind because I
feel like YouTube's are just American
thing and then there are people that are
just [ __ ] viral in that country and
they're youtubers there dude there's a
channel where a guy just goes to Asian
countries I think he's just in Japan and
he just eats vending food machine that
was yes it was like he doesn't eat meals
he his channel is him POV him and he
like goes up to a vending machine and he
he presses a button and then like it
makes like [ __ ] fish soup or
something oh right watch cause in Japan
is [ __ ] crazy right anything in a
[ __ ] a vending machine over there
there's a whole bunch of like expat like
American or British like vloggers in
Asia and all they do is
they're Asia experience it's kind of
like the remember the eatyourkimchi
couple that we met in Korea yeah
recently I saw them they move to Japan
and they're doing they're doing all
these like travel they're not travelling
cuz they lived there yeah and I'm like
dang dude this is crazy so I went down
this rabbit hole of never run out of
content could just go every just go
Asian country hoppy yeah yeah there's
just a lot of people out there just live
in and and they get millions of views
just eating food there I want you to
meet spaghetti and meatballs like I made
in a [ __ ] vending machine I would
watch it - it's crazy their vending
machines are crazy though you know we
went to Japan though I was really
disappointed that I didn't see more than
just drink vending machines I'm like
we're always dope as vending machines
people are always talking about making
news articles about and I didn't see any
of that well there's a drink vending
machine in the middle of forest yeah
literally everywhere so I'm like that's
not special anymore
Oh like you you never saw words that
makes the different ramen and stuff like
that yeah like the other vending
machines I did get to see is where they
just give you a ticket where you go up
and get your food but you have to make
it yeah they make like different kinds
of ramen or soups and stuff like that
they'll make anything it's crazy I'm
like [ __ ] this guy made eggs benedict
in the [ __ ] vending machine I'm like
how the [ __ ] I used to this person is
basically they just get like what do you
call it like a Steadicam and they walk
through famous cities it's just I
watching it's just like three hours of
footage of just walking through a city
it's like he's walking for three hours
yeah and it's what cuts - so it's me but
it but they're long takes so it's just
like imagine like clothing it huh you
makes you feel like you're there and
it's very calming yeah guy a guy just
like puts on a helmet cam he's on a
[ __ ] motorcycle or something or is in
his car and he's just driving through
the hood and drive it through like oh
it's called moto vlogging yeah yeah one
of my friends did does that in in Maui
and he just puts a cam on his head and
he just [ __ ] goes and dirt bikes
through the island and that's all we do
that now so this is kind of like the
river
cuz you know that usually things happen
in real life and then porn adapts to
that like movies and [ __ ] at the porn
version but the other way we're like POV
was on porn and then now it's like POV
experiences yeah it feels like I'm
playing on a first-person shooter game
but no one's shooting yeah it's weird
it's traveling I watched one where a guy
drove through Skid Row and I was like
yeah I mean I do the whole time it's
[ __ ] it's exactly like that but
people from around the world like well
no I found it in the playlist of the guy
driving through cities that's yeah
that's what's nuts is like we can pretty
much be at anywhere in the world now
just by a POV style right and Google
Maps that was the original way like
Apple maps they have these things called
like it's a 3d on the Apple map and then
you click on the 3d and it gives you
like a 3d tour like aerial tour of the
whole city and it takes you up to like
monuments yeah and that this was like
back in 2011 or 12 and I used to just
sit there in my room and like just
travel the world watching that you know
what I'm gonna do in the future they're
gonna have a rent my body and mind
experience where like you can [ __ ]
tap into what my day is like and how I'm
feeling and whatever I believe it yeah
but then you can feel it but you're
gonna choose who I pick can I have a
mountainous titties while I walk around
yeah that's true I might just looked at
hold on I might but at least I get to
know that I'm in a different place look
at the floor looks different I'll be
like hey you guys could tap into mine
today and then people tap into my daily
thing and I'm just doing whatever all
day long it's like a live stream but
like in real life or the chick tries to
look up and I'm like hey excuse me your
eyes are down here right now thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]